I know right my hair is today I look
like a treasure troll it's kind of cool
so I keep it
[Music]
Horrible Bosses 2 so Horrible Bosses 2
is the sequel to Horrible Bosses you
remember Horrible Bosses the three guys
who had bosses now hated him so like hey
let's kill our bosses in Horrible Bosses
2 the same three guys have come up with
an idea the shower pal is a thing that
goes in the shower and get you cleaning
there faster so you want to go into
business for themselves so they partner
up with Christoph Waltz and his kid
Chris Pine in this movie and those two
screw these three guys over because
getting screwed over is kind of their
lot in life so they're like alright we
need to get back at them and now we have
a new movie called Horrible Bosses 2 so
first of all these three guys in this
movie they're a great trio comedic Lee
they're good because you got Charlie day
he's looking the idiot he's the crazy
one Jason Bateman's like the quiet
methodical type-a left-brain personality
then Jason sudakis pseudo COO he's the
crude guy he's the loud one he's the
perb of the entire group so you have
these three guys now taking on but these
millionaires is a huge organization I
thought that was awesome you got a step
that [ __ ] up Chris Pines and the movies
funny how douchey Chris Pine is until it
stops being as funny you're like alright
dude shut up I'm and I am actually going
to give me the gun I'm gonna shoot him
I'm gonna shoot him the enemy does what
sequels usually do we should they have
their stride they're doing fine then it
tries to give you twists and turns
because it wants to be clever and one
twist is fine in the movie then it does
a few of them and you're like alright
you're not making the usual suspects
here man just make us laugh good example
of that for me is Dumb and Dumber to it
was a dumb ass movie for sure but I
laughed a lot in that movie this movie
was a dumb ass movie but I laughed
sometimes I credit that I'm gonna
absolutely give this movies the fact
they didn't try to do the exact same
thing as the last ones not like these
three guys have three different jobs and
now they all hate their bosses against
now they want to kill their bosses again
this movie tried to go in a different
direction and I like that shit's like
alright let's not rehash the same thing
as before let's try to do something new
and you have the entire returning cast
of the first one in this movie not just
the three guys but Jennifer Aniston's in
the movie Kevin Spacey's in the movie
Jamie Foxx's in the movie ultimately
when you start thinking about it you're
like two out of the three people in this
movie didn't have to be in this movie
they're here because do you want to have
them in the movie it's kind of like Mike
Tyson in the hangover 2 you're like you
didn't have to be at the end of this
movie ultimately the main three guys and
Horrible Bosses to carry this movie
because their chemistry is so damn good
together I felt like when the movie
tried to be hilarious
it was only kind of funny and the
funniest parts of the movie are the
subtle moments that were supposed to be
kind of funny that actually ended up
being really funny this movies kind of
like The Hangover 3 to Hangover 1 it
went a new direction it tried to be
funny but it tried to be so hard to be
funny and relevant that it was only you
know what kind of funny I can't remember
any scenes in this movie that had me
busting up laughing just gut-busting
laughing so in the end I'm gonna give
this movie the same exact score I gave
hangover 3 which is Horrible Bosses 2 is
a good time if you're drunk yeah now
it's a party hey tell another shitty
buzz story like you did in Horrible
Bosses 1 review if you guys will
remember my Horrible Bosses 1 review I
told you a story of a shitty boss that I
has a true story actual shitty boss it's
kind of a sequel to that in the sense
that the company that I worked for and
he worked for a contacted me and they
were like hey we really like your
YouTube channel we want to know if you
want to partner up with us this
partnership may be beneficial for both
our sakes I message back and I swear to
God I started the message by saying this
is the email I've been waiting for all
my life then I went on to say it look I
know that the 16 year old kid they
probably had email me you have nothing
to do with what I'm about to tell you so
just know that I'm not biting your head
off at all that being said you should
know a few things and that is I've
worked for the shitty company that you
have worked for I have worked overtime
hours and I've seen them you moved my
overtime hours onto my next paycheck to
avoid paying me overtime I dealt with
shitty manchild managers I dealt with an
HR department that would do nothing
about any problem I had been contacted I
saw arguably the worst boss I've ever
had
bully and intimidate sixteen-year-old
kids like teenage kids just trying to
get a few extra dollars I want you to
send this up the chain up the corporate
ladder of the company that you work for
so hopefully the owners or the
executives whoever needs to see it can
see it let them know that I said quote I
will eat [ __ ] and die before I work with
your company on any level ever again
I felt pretty good so people companies
CEOs managers whoever
don't let shitty people work for you cuz
that might cost you something that you
might want later on in life so do you
have a shitty horrible boss story and
who was it and did you ever get to tell
them to go [ __ ] themselves whatever it
is comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you
[Music]